the gyro can experience now since 2004
have there been plans implemented to
clean up and also restore waterways and
all the different absolutely yeah
absolutely and so now there's like a
whole they realize this is an issue and
so there's there's precedent there's
very much so and and that largely came
from what we saw you know in those early
years the 2004 first stop on down there
on Dexter Canyon Creek and then what we
had on Sierra Zul when my partner was
shot in 2005 about then we started also
see the banned poisons in these grows
like the carbo fury on bottles and just
to give a background this stuff is so
deadly it was made as an insecticide
rodenticide just to kill anything that
you put on any type of agricultural
product and it was made originally back
and I think like the 50s for legitimate
agriculture and then they found out how
toxic it was an EPA banned it from use
or even possession it's a felony to have
it in the country and use it anywhere
without special licenses through
legitimate channels here in America and
they ban it like 15 years ago because it
was so nasty but because it does keep
everything off the marijuana plants I
mean nothing can even get near it
without dying almost instantly they
still get it in third-world countries
they can get it in Mexico and it gets
smuggled across the border with the grow
groups the the drug trafficking groups
because it's so effective regardless out
poison it is and we were starting to see
more and more of that stuff as we were
starting to ramp more of a specialty to
do in this job more you know thoroughly
and safely and get into the cleanup now
this is one of the many things I brought
this up with Dan Crenshaw the other day
and I talked about you and because he's
against federally making marijuana
federally legal and I said one of the
problems with it being illegal is this
and I was explaining these grow-ops that
for the rest of the country where
marijuana is illegal right the vast
majority like what was the number that
you said the percentage that was has
grown in California that's illegally
sold through the rest of the country 70
80 percent so 70% of the entire
marijuana population or marijuana
product that you're buying if you live
in in place like South Dakota wherever I
don't even know it's legal in South
Dakota wherever it's illegal
they're buying it from here exactly and
it's because one of the reasons is
because our state laws say that well
first of all we're close to Mexico so
the cartel members can come up really
quickly right and then the other problem
is that our state laws when we made
marijuana legal recreationally here weak
severely lowered the penalty for an
illegal grow-op it became a misdemeanor
correct that was the that was the thing
you know when when we started the the
department's special team the the
SpecOps marijuana enforcement team that
hid more goes into part of my job is
being the co-founder of that and the
team leader was outreach so I was
speaking to legislative groups before we
legalized under Prop 64 and then the
tighter medicinal marijuana laws that
came about that same time and I was
talking to anybody conservation groups
that you and I would you know be part of
preservation animal rights groups high
school kids you know it assemblies right
watch out you know if you're using weed
make sure you're not using this stuff
because it's so nasty things like that
and my whole point was if we're gonna
regulate guys we see it comin let's just
regulate smart let's not lessen any
penalties for the trespass grow that the
cartels are doing in our public lands
and private lands and also the other
gang groups and there's there's other
groups you know to a smaller extent but
unfortunately when we did regulate and
all that was passed two years ago they
did water it down so public land
cultivation went to like you said a
felony to a misdemeanor and if you're a
juvenile cultivator on public private
land and one of these juvenile you know
cartel members and there's a lot of
young ones learning it's a it's an
infraction and that took a lot of
emphasis away from that part of the
problem and left us out there basically
alone with a couple other agencies to
fight it well for the average person
that would sound before you knew about
the cartel grows that would sound like a
good idea well hey if marijuana is legal
what's the problem what's a big deal
exactly then the other problem is these
people that are buying this marijuana in
the rest of the country it's highly
likely that they're gonna have some of
that pesticide on it right and how bad
is that stuff is that stuff ever killed
someone from smoking this illegal
marijuana we don't know if it's killed
anybody directly because by the time it
gets
distributed throughout the country it
does dissipate a little bit but it's
still highly toxic to put it in
perspective about three years ago we had
two federal officers back east not even
in California in a public land grow that
had all that toxic on it so they have
cartel grows out there they do they do
they actually coast we have them in
about 20 25 to 27 other states to a much
lesser extent and something we need to
look at is California
I mean we're one of only six
Mediterranean climates on the whole
globe so we are a great weed growing
state just like our wine industry man we
got great great weather for it so we can
grow outdoors and indoors
I mean February - almost December right
and that's why it's grown here and
that's why the black market both in you
know the private land communities and
the cartels are everywhere across the
country with this stuff but they'll go
wherever they can - you know diversify
the network so we do have it in other
states to a much lesser extent and then
something we need to remember is even
though about half the country has these
grows in them to a lesser extent than
California these same groups are under
the same Enterprise they're humid doing
human trafficking doing gun running you
know to fuel the the fight down in
Mexico methamphetamine production and
now the new synthetic fentanyl that's
just killing thousands especially on the
East Coast are coming from these groups
so it's all one enterprise and of course
we focus on the cannabis issue because
that's what's affecting our while lands
in our waterways it's right at the hub
so yeah it is it's it's nationwide it's
not a California problem and we made
really really careful even though we're
talking about a team in California game
wardens we're trying to tell a
nationwide story because the nation
needs to know
[Applause]